we're going to dive straight in with our
main story tonight this is our final
show of the year so we thought we'd
focus on someone who's had a pretty big
12 months Elon Musk a man who can pull
off pretty much any bad guy in a movie
look there's a Lex Luther posing for the
cover of metropolis Maniacs monthly
there's why no Mr Bond I and my child
bride expect you to die there's I just
bought your media company I'm about to
strip you for parts there's spaces first
racist sheriff and finally the less
reimagining of Billy Zayn's
character in Titanic truly the man has
range Elon has made news all year from
test launching the most powerful rocket
ever built to just this week having to
recall two million cars due to safety
concerns he even challenged Mark
Zuckerberg to a cage fight to which
Zuckerberg replied send me location and
may I suggest to both of them interior
volcano and then of course there is
Twitter he now calls it X but the rest
of us still call it Twitter he
officially acquired it 12 months ago and
since then it has been one Fiasco after
another with the most recent coming when
he tweeted his agreement with this
anti-semitic post calling the great
replacement Theory the actual truth that
caused many big advertisers to flee and
then in the midst of denying any
anti-semitic intent Elon decided to
taunt the sponsors who had left don't
advertise you don't want them to
advertise no what do you
mean if somebody's going to try to
Blackmail me with advertising blackmail
me with money go
yourself but go
yourself is that
clear I hope it is wow it is hard to say
what's most embarrassing there the fact
that the world's richest man is's
playing the you're not breaking up with
me I'm breaking up with you card or that
he's doing it to confused silence while
wearing a jacket from Ralph Lauren's
midlife crisis collection he's clearly
going for bad boy there but ended up
looking more like red pilled chip from
Rescue
Rangers now that clip actually made the
rounds but for my money this exchange a
few seconds later is even better no
actually what what this advertising
boycott is uh is is going to do it's
going to kill the
company and you think that I but and the
whole world will know
that those advertisers killed the
company and we will document it in great
detail but there those advertisers I
imagine are going to say they're going
to say we didn't kill the company oh
yeah they're going to say tell to tell
it to Earth let's see how Earth responds
to that yeah tell it to Earth and I
honestly hope he does that I hope he
tries telling every living creature on
the planet including those weird deep
sea fish all about how Advertiser
boycotts are going to kill Twitter just
so one of them can open its objectively
horrifying jaws and say Yeah man cuz you
said that weird about juice we live
in a black void and even we understand
the order of operations here and look I
could talk for hours about what Elon has
done to Twitter many in the media do
because it's where they spend most of
their work days but the truth is it's
not the most important thing Elon is in
charge of it's arguably not even the
most important social networking site we
all know the only social media app that
matters these days is the comment
section of venmo that is where the real
drama
is what musk's time at Twitter has
definitely changed is how many people
perceive him because for a long time he
was seen as a one of a kind genius who'd
save humanity and was described as a
real life iron man it's a comparison
that he even welcomed Cameo as himself
in Iron Man 2 although I never really
liked those comparisons as far as I'm
concerned the only real life iron man is
Troy Herby who spent his entire life
designing a suit of armor that could
withstand a grizzly bear attack and was
kind enough to film the tests are you
ready Troy I'm ready here it
comes
yes that is the hero we
deserve that is my Iron Man still for a
long time elon's Public Image was that
of a Maverick celebrity inventor who cut
through red tape revolutionized space
travel and made electric cars cool and
he does do a lot in addition to Twitter
he's the head of five other companies
Tesla SpaceX the boring company
neuralink and xai and thanks to their
roller coaster fortunes he can claim the
twin distinctions of being both the
richest person in the world and the
first person ever to lose $200 billion
which is hard to even wrap your head
around it's like hearing someone won a
marathon after accidentally running 200
miles in the wrong
direction and to hear Elon tell it he's
been doing this at least in part to
benefit Humanity he recently said of
Tesla I've done more for the envir
enironment than any single human on
earth demonstrating a pretty strong
Messianic streak in fact samman the CEO
of open AI who's both worked with and
clashed with Musa said Elon desperately
wants the world to be saved but only if
he can be the one to save it which is a
pretty big asterisk it's like Jesus says
in the Book of Matthew love thy neighbor
but more importantly me and if you don't
you find your own Heaven Jay
Grizzle out and I know there are people
who love Elon and people who utterly
hate him and there are going to be parts
of this piece that irritate both groups
there are also people who would
understandably rather just ignore him
but as you will see we might have passed
the point where that is an option for
any of us so tonight let's look at Elon
Musk and let's start with how he earned
his business genius reputation I'm going
to skip over the early years the growing
up in aparte South Africa then
immigrating to the US via Canada during
his college Years you can read any
number of books on that or just ask your
next bump Umble date who turned up in a
fedora and a released the SN cut T-shirt
ready to spend the entire night talking
about it Elon first earned his fortune
from creating a company called zip 2
with his brother before going on to help
run PayPal alongside Peter teal and if I
could only have been a fly on that wall
I'd have flown straight into a hot light
bulb he then invested that personal
Fortune into space x a company that
would create and launch its own rockets
and spacecraft and that is a pretty
gutsy move to go from an online payment
system to literal rocket science
although as some point out SpaceX wasn't
exactly starting from Square One what
SpaceX has been very successful at is
taking basically off-the-shelf
technology stuff that was developed by
NASA 50 years ago and streamlining it so
in that way he's kind of the Henry Ford
of of of space because Henry Ford didn't
invent the automobile he just figured
out how to make the automobile you know
commercially viable yeah like Henry Ford
Elon Musk managed to build on the
technology that others had invented uh
that's not actually the only way he's
like Henry Ford which you'd know if you
ever Googled either of their names in
the word anti-Semitism but let's not get
ahead of ourselves here the point is
musk took a big risk on starting a
rocket company which nearly didn't work
his first three attempts to launch one
failed and then he made a truly
audacious gamble when you had that third
failure in a row did you think I need to
pack this in never
why not I don't ever give up 8 weeks
later musk bet the company on another
flight we have lift off and this time
around everything worked
perfect if that fourth launch hadn't
worked that would have been it um we
would have not had the resources to
mount a fth you couldn't have gone on at
that point we it yes death would have
been I think inevitable that is
genuinely impressive although I will say
there are less weird ways to say we
would have gone out of business then
death is inevitable phrasing matters
it's why people say we just had a baby
instead of Lisa life out of her HOA
same meaning different
feeling and that Trend continued through
spacex's subsequent effort something
that as this former head of NASA points
out is not something that they would
ever be able to get away with if we lost
rockets at the rate that that that Elon
Musk loses his big Starship would have
been out of business Congress would have
shut us down if we lost one Starship let
alone six or however many it's been we
can't do that right the US government
can't waste billions of dollars just
blowing things up in the vague hope that
it'll somehow turn into a success unless
of course those things are Iraq or
Afghanistan so SpaceX began with a big
gamble had a flirtation With Disaster
and then became a massive success and
that patent persisted with Tesla that
company was was funded in part by
pre-selling cars to Future owners only
to run into repeated production delays
and spiraling costs just watch musk at
one meeting of those early buyers where
he told them that the price had gone up
on the cars that they'd already bought
we took faith in you and now you're just
turning around and changing the price on
us not telling us and then we find out
about backwards and now we're kind of V
hurt because we weren't told we can't
sell cars for you know less than they
cost us to produce if if anything more
behind more than that it could than it
was an accident there's a bunch of
comments after it that all
okay there seemed to be a little bit of
Anger from some people in the room um
who felt that we' kind of done a bait
and switch uh and I mean that's that's
sort of a little bit true that there was
a bit of a bait and switch I mean it's
uh that that's I mean kind of what
happened it was very tough yeah you
could see how baiting customers with one
price and switching it for another might
be considered a bait and switch there's
actually a great econ book on the
subject entitled words mean what words
mean and yet Tesla is now a big success
with factories on three continents
delivering over a million Vehicles a
year meanwhile SpaceX is currently
valued around 150 billion making one of
the most valuable private companies in
the world although it is worth noting
that his boldness sometimes comes with a
tendency to overpromise and show off
products long before they are ready like
in 2019 when mus decided to demonstrate
how indestructible his new Cyber truck
was by having its chief designer Chuck a
steel ball at its window Bron could you
try to break this glass
[Applause]
[Music]
please
yeah sure
yeah oh my well
maybe that was a little too
hard yeah not great but also kind of
charming I'll be honest there is
something I kind of like about the Cyber
truck I mean I don't want to own one or
drive near one it's basically a £7,000
smooshed up refrigerator moving at 60 M
an hour being driven by odds are a real
piece of but there is something
appealing about a man so passionate
about his idea that he's willing to
ignore questions about Aesthetics
performance durability practicality
safety and who on Earth actually want to
spend up to $100,000 to drive every
child's first attempt at drawing a car
and build it anyway and that's not his
only embarrassing product launch two
years ago he introduced a Tesla robot by
showcasing a prototype that was just a
dancer in a robot bodysuit and it was
exactly as dumb as that
sounds
[Music]
I absolutely love it apparently all you
have to do to launch a robotics company
is invest in a spandex bodysuit and a
dancer so with that in mind behold my
new
creation the robot race is on Elo the
race is on look at him go okay okay
enough enough robot enough enough enough
enough you you can power down Rob thank
you for your
service
look embarrassing moment aside there is
a lot to like about elon's companies
SpaceX has made real achievements like
reusable rocket technology and making
space easier and more affordable to
access and Tesla has pushed automakers
to take electric cars seriously in a way
that would have seemed impossible 20
years ago but as one of elon's critics
points out there are costs to that
progress that often get overlooked is
Elon Musk a net positive for society I
would argue he is I think the EV race is
a great thing space exploration is
really hopeful and just kind of
inspiring the problem is with the word
net and that is once we decide an
individual or a company is a net good
for society we don't want to hold him or
the company accountable for anything
right even if you think Elon is a net
positive it doesn't mean that we
shouldn't talk about the that he's doing
along the way and let's start with his
employees many of whom have called Elon
a nightmare to work for and not just at
Twitter where he fired most of the staff
and ordered the rest to work in quote
extremely hardcore mode he's been like
this at every company is this early
employee at SpaceX will attest it was
not unusual to have a phone call from
him at 3: in the morning on your cell
phone you better by God have that next
to your bed to answer he's just gone
into yelling fits against me telling me
I'm stupid and I don't know what I'm
talking about and and I've seen him do
it to other very intelligent people so
he'll definitely find your weakness in
your personality in your in your
character in your in your spirit and uh
I wouldn't say exploit it but you you'll
definitely uh crack well that sounds
unpleasant not just your boss calling to
abuse you but because there are only two
reasons someone should be calling you at
3: in the morning and they are because a
a loved one is having an emergency and
need your help or your house is on fire
and even then that could have been a
text and the Damage isn't just emotional
workers at his factories complain of
immense pressure and unrealistic
deadlines a report a few years ago on
his Tesla Factory in Fremont California
found employees complaining that style
and speed trumped safety and that
workers there have been sliced by
Machinery crushed by forklifts burned in
electrical explosions and sprayed with
molten metal one worker even claimed
that she'd been told Elon didn't want
signs or anything yellow like caution
tape in the factory which isn't good
because caution tape is important it
lets people know something might be
dangerous and unstable like a skull and
crossbones on a bottle or this jacket on
a middle-aged M now now Tesla does deny
that but its claims about its factories
can be hard to verify even when
Regulators try to get involved at musk's
companies they can be strongly resisted
for example his Nevada Giga Factory at
one point denied entry to State Osan
inspectors for nearly 3 months
which is ridiculous the word gigafactory
alone should be enough to Warrant an
immediate inspection but it's not just
workers who mus is willing to put at
risk sometimes it's his own customers
he's long been developing self-driving
car technology and has sometimes
knowingly exaggerated its capabilities
the two pieces of software available are
called autopilot and full self-driving
but despite their names neither system
can drive a car on its own yet in this
2016 ad it appears to be doing just that
Amplified by the the introductory text
that Elon personally asked for which
reads the car is driving itself but that
was extremely misleading it was driving
along a pre-planned route it was only
self-driving the way that your nana
self-drives herself up and down the
stairs and Tesla will note they tell
drivers they should keep their hands on
the wheel and take over if anything goes
wrong and I sure hope drivers do that
because he's been inviting them to try
out full self-driving in beta mode
basically having drivers find the bugs
in new software even on complicated city
streets and with predictable results
we're going to make this left
turn and I'm getting honked at I just
but now it just turn
right we're supposed to go left Ogen is
not a professional test driver nor is he
a Tesla employe instead he's one of the
over 50,000 customers that Tesla has
allowed to access FSD beta we just ran a
red light we just ran a red light that
is pretty alarming especially the moment
where you see people pushing a stroller
way too close to that car because even
if Tesla drivers volunteered to take
part in this high stakes experiment the
people around them sure didn't no one
got a push alert on their phone saying
hey Tesla here please consent to take
part in the beta test that's currently
hurtling towards you do hurry time is a
factor and musk have taken a pretty blly
attitude towards self-driving ding
deaths in 2016 when concerns were first
emerging he told reporters that if they
wrote stories that dissuaded people from
using autonomous Driving Systems or
Regulators from approving them then they
would be killing people essentially
arguing that any deaths in the present
day will be more than offset by lives
saved later and just this week when the
Washington Post noted that they tallied
about 40 fatal or serious crashes
involving Tesla's driver assistant
software Tesla responded by saying we
believe it is morally indefensible not
to make these systems available to a
wider set of consumers given the
incontrovertible data that shows it's
saving lives and preventing injury but
rather than producing that data it
promised more detailed information will
be publicly available in the near future
which I'm sorry is just not data
behavior and that is coming from TV's
number one data anyone who
collects incontrovertible data would
give you a more specific date than the
near future because data as we
all know are also calendar
and look I know myself and look
history is littered with titans of
business who were shitty or broken
people from Thomas Edison through Henry
Ford through Steve Jobs the difference
is by and large they didn't open up
their brain to let the whole world have
a constant look inside but Elon does and
the glimpses we get can be terrifying
and that brings us back to Twitter musk
has been a heavy user four years putting
out classic tweets like I put the art in
fart 69 days after 420 20 again haha and
technically alcohol is a solution which
technically isn't a joke and his
biographer will tell you he's addicted
to the app to a genuinely problematic
extent one day he was traveling with a
friend Antonio gracias and musk had kept
tweeting late at night doing these
ridiculous tweets sometimes very harmful
ones and so the friend said let me take
your phone and I'm going to put it in
the safe here in the hotel room friend
punches in the code and said that way
you can't use it late at night at 3:00
in the morning musk calls hotel security
to get him to open the safe and he
starts doing tweets he was addicted to
tweeting look I am sure when the average
security guard is called up to a
Billionaire's hotel room at 3:00 a.m.
they have a list of things to expect and
it begins and ends with dead body so it
must have been a pleasant surprise when
he wheeled an empty garbage bin into the
room I he finded Elon Musk punching
random numbers into his hotel safe just
cuz he thought of I put the art in fart
and the whole world simply had to know
and look elon's tweets were never that
great not like mine of course which are
Banger after Banger after Banger after
certified Banger I don't miss but in
recent years they've taken a turn toward
the nasty and conspiratorial getting
increasingly into the realm of
right-wing trolls and many point to one
particular moment as the Turning Point
here the pandemic lockdowns California
has 40 million residents are in lockdown
at the time the government had ordered
musk to close his Tesla factories in
California I mean he was pissed that his
factories were kind of forced to close
ultimately yes that's the thing he
wanted them there and he wanted them
working he thought it was the it was an
existential crisis if Tesla didn't
succeed he really that for the world for
all of us and then it got weird free
America now people their freedom back in
California have been half empty this
whole time people back their freedom
musk told his employees that he intended
to defy orders and go to work CEO Elon
Musk tweeted I will be on the line with
everyone else if anyone is arrested I
ask that it only be me okay what that
really drives home is just how different
musk is from the rest of us because
there is Rich and detached and then
there's I've asked the cops not to
arrest anyone else so we should be good
rich and detached and look let's admit a
lot of our brains got a bit broken
during the pandemic I I think we can all
agree that it' be really cool if the
entirety of the pandemic chapter in
future history textbook simply read
weird time had to be there we did our
best but Elon didn't Channel his anxiety
in one of the normal ways like spraying
groceries with disinfectant getting
really into sourdough bread baking or
tracking down and purchasing one of a
kind rat erotica you know normal stuff
that we all did instead his brain broke
in the direction of right Wingers who
were loudly opposing the shutdowns and
once he started siding with them over
those complaints he found himself
sympathizing with their broader concerns
about a woke mind virus and that they
were being mocked and shadowbanned and
generally disrespected by Twitter and
since he was also the richest man in the
world he could fix all of this by simply
buying the whole thing which is what he
then did and I don't have time to run
through every bad decision that he's
made at Twitter although real quick he
cut about 80% of the staff dissolved the
trust and Safety Council blew up the
verification system exercised the same
censorship he claimed to be against Rea
reactivated the accounts of various
White supremacists released the Twitter
files in which he basically misook the
email of various feckless left leaning
Tech weenie struggling with the
impossible job of content moderation for
a vast Elite conspiracy to sign its
right-wing changed the name to
X put a gigantic X on the building which
he then took down and just this week
reversed his early decision and let Alex
Jones back onto the site a decision
that's be met with resounding praise
from big loud
quarterly and notably his time in charge
of Twitter has seen a rise in unpleasant
rhetoric from musk himself including
boosting a transphobic documentary
saying every parent should watch this
responding interesting to a tweet
reading blacks kill each other whites
kill themselves and boosting this office
meme falsely implying there had been a
cover up about pizzagate I didn't think
it was possible but it genuinely makes
me miss the man who once posted send me
your danst memes and this pict from a
turtle on Wheels with the message
science has gone too far and while Elon
will dispute there has been a rise in
hate speech on the platform or that he
has panded to White nationalists you
know who disagrees with him on that
white nationalists just listen to Nick
fenes telling Richard Spencer everything
Elon has done for their movement it's
only been a year since musk acquired
Twitter which is not really a long time
and the changes didn't even begin to
roll out until less than a year ago and
yet the change has been dramatic how
much the window has shifted noticeably
on issues like white identity which
apparently is suddenly mainstream it
wasn't for a long time it seemed like
Charlie Kirk said one or two things
about it last year and then this year
now everyone's a white nationalist now
everyone's a white identitarian you open
up one of the social platforms it's so
hot it's so fast it changes public
opinion virtually overnight and and
really in our favor wow all of that is
horrifying but the use of the term white
identitarian is just not fooling anyone
that is what the word racist writes on a
job application to make it sound like it
went to
college and the fact Elon seems to be
getting increasingly radicalized is a
big problem because we've put a lot of
power into his hands and much more than
you may realize remember when I said
that no one is taking the big swings
that he is that includes the government
and over the years that means a lot of
things that this country relies on have
been outsourced to musk every day musk's
companies control more of the internet
power grid transportation system objects
in orbit the nation's security
infrastructure and its energy Supply to
take just one example SpaceX has now put
more than 4,500 starlink satellite ites
into orbits meaning that musk's company
now accounts for over half of all active
satellites and that puts the US
government in a bit of a bind just watch
a National Security Council spokesman
try to explain why it wouldn't be acting
in response to elon's boosting of that
great replacement Theory tweet there's
Innovation out there in the private
sector that we'd be foolish to to to
walk away from I'm not aware of any
specific
efforts uh to address to to address our
concerns over his rhetoric uh but that
doesn't mean that we accept uh or or uh
or agree with or condone in any way that
anti-semitic rhetoric that he pushed
yeah we're now at the point where the
government is explicitly saying we've
chosen to look the other way on the
anti-Semitism thing or as it's more
commonly known a daddy's home too and
the problem isn't just the Optics of
having someone as erratic as Elon in
charge of half the world satellites his
opinions can change the shape of world
events when Russia invaded Ukraine one
of their first actions was to S its
internet access now musk to his credit
agreed to provide Ukraine access to his
starlink Network and donated Hardware
enabling them to reach the internet via
satellite and they were very grateful
Lieutenant taras baret is a spokesman
for Ukraine's military he told us
Starling is crucial for commanding
troops on the battlefield Elon mus we've
been so grateful to space 6 and to Elon
Musk we all starling think uh none of
our offensives would be so successful
it's true the Ukrainian military was
Greatful to SpaceX and Elon Musk which
is one of those headlines that even a
few years ago would have sounded
impossible like Panera Bread's lemonade
linked to second death and Henry
Kissinger finally dead and by the way
I'm pretty sure it's the lemonade that
got him but as time went on Elon toyed
with the idea of withdrawing staring
service complaining that the cost was
too high even as he seemed increasingly
Russia friendly at one point he said
Russia should be allowed to Annex
Ukrainian land and tweeted a proposed
peace plan that would essentially just
give Russia everything they wanted
perhaps most notably he refused the
Ukrainian request to activate starlink
in Crimea enabling them to launch an
attack on Russian ships reportedly
because a Russian official warned him
that that could lead to a nuclear
response now guess that must be true
right what are Russian officials going
to do lie to an easily flattered CEO to
get exactly what they want I don't see
it
and look Elon still insists that he is
pro Ukraine and okay but us officials
are now in the awkward position of
having to defer to him on policy one
Pentagon spokesman even said that he let
a reporter interview an official only if
musk gave permission saying we'll talk
to you if Elon wants us to which isn't
great you know before I respond on
behalf of the mightiest military on
Earth let me just run this up the chain
and make sure it's cool with Admiral
dank memes
420 Elon Musk could not have humiliated
the Pentagon anymore if he'd opened up
his own building next door called the
hexagon the Pentagon that
now the Pentagon has since signed
a contract with Starling to take over
certain services and rely Less on musk's
whim but even elon's own biographer has
expressed unease about just how
important he's become so how does Elon
feel about having this much Global power
you know he says to me how am I in the
middle of this but frankly he loves it
he loves drama he loves being the epic
hero I think it is a little bit
dangerous because he loves it too much
wait he loves drama I'm sorry I'm really
not that comfortable with one of the
most powerful people on Earth being
summed up the same way you described
Andy Cohen on New Year's
Eve look the fact is whether we like it
or not and the answer is absolutely not
a huge number of very important things
going forward are going to depend on how
Elon is feeling which is a terrifying
thing thing to say about anyone but
especially this guy so so what can be
done here well it's actually simple we
just create a robust infrastructure
economy that can resist Easy
monopolization by private firms headed
by overconfident billionaires and we do
it about 15 years ago two problems with
that one time machines don't exist and
two the only person with the resources
and ambition to build one is the last
guy that you'd want to do that cuz he'
probably use it to go back in time and
high five Baby
Hitler and look I'll be honest my
feelings about Elon changed a bit in the
writing of this piece I'm probably now
more impressed by what he's doing but
more worried by the fact that he's the
one who's been doing it because he
cultivates an image that he's simply too
Visionary too original to play by other
people's rules and he waves away the
damage that he does as the cost of
innovation and saving Humanity but the
truth is that way of thinking isn't
remotely original we've seen it so many
times before the least surprising thing
on earth is a middle-aged billionaire
CEO with self-serving libertarian views
increasingly racist politics and a
messiah complex and it is long past time
that he faced the kind of accountability
that should come with that and not just
from the echo chamber that he bought
himself online but from everyone whose
lives are very much affected by him and
I know Elon might be unhappy with this
piece he he might even permanently
delete my Twitter account which is fine
by me after all when this absolute
treasure is gone elon's the one who will
have to explain why to the
Earth and he might say he's saving
Humanity what have I ever done what
industries have I revolutionized and I
admit nothing yet but may I remind you
I've already taken the first step toward
building a robot Empire Bow Down and
Worship your Metal Gods bounce bounce
bounce bounce bounce
bounce